i put my bones into them i make them
gorgeous ladies
all of them and i never mess with ugly
ducklings
but i put my bones in them so i teach
them
i put it in them and i bring the best
out of them so they all been great
every one of them but i don't have a
gang government
you can't imagine from 63 all the way up
to today
i can't be mad about nothing
all right virgil virgil uh where are you
from where'd you grow up
i grew up in fresno california and uh
tell me about your uh
childhood you had both your parents
growing up both of my parents was around
growing up
good childhood great childhood
no no terrible traumas or abuse or
anything like that
none at all what kind of role models did
you have as a kid
role models i had as a kid if you go all
the way back to childhood
it was just little guys that come up
that i knew from my kids that's wrong
with my fathers my
uncles and people of that nature but as
i got older
off into school
it was pimps players
max that i kind of
was looking up to as far as uh
in my teen hood you know this was in uh
fresno
fresno yeah what is the difference
between a pimp and a mac
difference between a pimp and a mac a
pimp is one to start out
from the bottom floor from the beginning
you start
out being a player you're growing to be
a pimp because other guys just
got prostitutes on the street that's
what everybody
uh is caught affiliated with and a mac
is one that really have got his game all
the way together
he's the top pimp of everything when you
become a mac
actually they called her mcdaddy but i
don't even like the word that i used the
word mac
that's why when you go all the way back
to the movie the mac and the film
i know you're kind of familiar with that
right that's why they name it the mac
because when you're pimping you haven't
elevated to being a mac yet
i understood what age were you when you
first got into it
i was like 17 16 17. and then you said
you had like role models
yeah i had a role model i had an older
girl that liked me was trying to take me
out of
my home when i was a kid she was a
prostitute
she come my mother and asked her because
she had my mother told her no
so the girl and myself kind of messed
around for a lot of years she used to
give me money
in there you know as a young kid i
didn't know anything about the game you
know i just knew what she did
and she liked me all those years you
know so that's kind of how i got my feet
wet
initially until i graduated looking to
the big giant players riding on the
streets in the brand new cars and stuff
i've heard this from several pimps that
yeah the
wit the the girls sometimes choose you
right right with you no doubt you
intimidating them and the classic
idea of you you coerced or forced or
whatever them into doing it
the girls come to you and say please do
this for me well
actually it's like a trend
back in the day nobody had any money
so you know where we all come from i
don't care what they say or how they say
it
we didn't come from no whole lot of
money so anything for us getting money a
little easy as far as a woman giving it
to you
we're going to jump on that especially
if women liked us and i was warned that
all the women liked it so that's kind of
how i got my feet wet
yeah and then your you would have how
many girls
uh at what time i used to stay six seven
deep consistently when i was like
21 22 years old i was like six or seven
deep you know but i was just really
getting my feet wet just doing things
that
i was taught as a youngster see when i
got into the life
i was like uh very very young and i had
older players that are like 20 years
older than me
that took to me because i acted older
they liked how i carried myself
and they kind of took me on a wing it
just really fed me the game
from a professional way so that's kind
of how
i got into the life you know so
all the older gentlemen's
players pimps
you know they call the pimps players max
all that back in the day
but all of those wanted me to be better
than what they were
out of all the youngsters coming up they
told me i was going to be the best
i don't know what they was looking at
what they saw
i didn't have no experience in life
harley
but i followed the steps of what they
said years ago
what are the qualities a pimp needs to
to excel
you got to have personal style
you have to have your tools in order you
have to uh
spread your wings like batman you know
you got to
have uh if you don't know much you can't
do much
big game is play smooth out of sight
and the last thing if you don't have a
uh
uh knowledge of really how this game go
which a lot of guys was getting taught
by older players all the players had
more experience
so they would weave all the young
players out and shoot them to the left
and tell them something
that i see a lot of players is standing
on today
but really it was a it was just
something to get them out of the way
because they
seemed they were going to mess up the
game they didn't want to tell them they
weren't ready
so they shot them to the left and say
all i do
is drop the p nothing else
i come up with some of the most majors
players in the country
i was there when when the ward brothers
used to kick across the table sit around
and kick it that was my personal friend
come to my house i ride with them and
everything
they all looked up to me as a gentleman
of leisure because i always hallow my
business
if you run out of game you're going to
run out of money
so you have to be taught right in this
game in order to take this game to the
next level and elevate your game
so most guys i don't care what they say
like my mother told me years ago you
only have
one hole to crawl into even a wreck got
more than that
so you have to know something a little
uh more than just sending a woman to the
track
which that's my major thing i had women
that i sent to the track all my life i
just stopped it
recently because i elevated my game
took it to another level i have people
guessing
say can nobody do it like that and we
will walk and say different things
but they all i do is dress and rest and
ride that's all i've ever done
they try to say i'm doing this and i'm
doing that i'm not doing none of that
i'm with the basic and i'm winning with
it
now i'm keep on rocking with the same
program i'm have
all these years knowledge is power
if you don't like to say you don't know
much you can't do much you have to know
something actually your women gonna
respect it
the world gonna respect it everybody's
gonna respect it when you're standing on
top
i don't want to prison and ain't
lost nothing got a house built from
penitentiary
i bought hotels and about wedding
chapels in vegas
and it's all on knowledge on what you
know sure i accept my money from this
and that
but you have to know what you do money
and a fool will soon part with the
quickness
i've been down for 57 years straight on
top of my game
i got records that never be broke never
have and never will
and all the guys that gave the game to
me
they was proud of me because it's just
like your father and your mother
they'd be great but they want you to be
better than they are
i never take my mothers and father's
position because they're my mother and
father
but as far as position i would pass them
up
and that's what i did with my friends i
stayed on top
for years i'm still on top handling my
business because
of knowledge what i was taught back in
the day who was the most important
uh like parent or a role model you had
as a kid
mom dad or somebody else my parents as a
kid
because they taught me a lot of things i
still remember things my mother taught
me
when i was three or four years old she
told me one time
i went to the refrigerator early in the
morning excuse me
she said boy go in there you ain't gonna
cover my kitchen don't wash your hands
i see i i took a bath and watched him
last night she said you know done
everything while you asleep
you don't know what you'd have done i
never forgot that and still staying with
me today
so all the older guys even the winos and
everybody that was only me i learned
something from all of them
they might not be the winners themself
but the things they taught me
stuck to me and i use it all the way to
the day and it works
what qualities do you look for in a
female
i look for females dedicated to the man
the one that's qualified
enough to listen to the instructions the
guidance and the one that's uh
down by law those are the ones i look
for because you got a lot of women
that's uh really uh
their hair strong nowadays you know you
got to really be about to really make
them understand what's going on
because they'll try to uh uh tell you
something if you ain't sharp enough to
tell them nothing
so you really got to be about your
business if you don't
if you lay off it ain't gonna pay off so
you got to be down and dirty about your
business
they can really respect you as they man
when when one of your girls gets a
little headstrong or gets out of line
you check them you don't never stop
you'll never stop being a man and that's
what they're going to respect
in the prison time that you did what was
that for i had uh
i did prison time for drugs
and what happened was i did a friend of
mine a favor
i was on top of the world that was 30
years ago
i had 20 cars five houses million
dollars for jury
every mink coat that you can that you
can even
imagine money stacked up this high
they stripped me and took everything
sent me the penitentiary
it cost me everything and all i was
doing was dressing the wrestling right
doing friends favors sometimes favors
will cost you
because if you fall off your game your
game gonna fall off you
it's gonna charge you so i caught a drug
case
everybody thought i was dealing drugs
i don't deal no drugs and ain't never
dealt none
but that's what they think because
anytime you're doing things above level
they're going to give you a perception
of what they think because
they haven't been sharp enough go to the
next level
and think that your brain and your
mindset
can give you a bigger
playing field to play on
instead of them spreading their mindset
on what
the see you're only going to be bigger
as the ones that taught you the game
i learned mine from giants all the way
from the rooted to the tutor
i learned it from giants i stuck by the
strip and it works
i add on to what i know i was smart in
school
i took the school and turned into the
game that's what makes me wait
did you have sex with the girls sure i
had sex with my girls
got babies by a couple of them how many
kids do you have
i got eight kids i've heard the bishop
talk about
like stealing sometimes the girls the
girls sometimes will steal from
from john's is that is that every part
of the game where the girls will like
rob guys well john the girls
see when their girls start flat backing
all these years
they flat back they call it flat backing
so they can only get so much money flat
backing but somebody comes through with
great big money
and they learn how to steal they're
gonna take it and that's just how it was
if mark put himself in that position she
going to get it
that's part of the game that's part of
the game
my girls just get so much money and then
holler they didn't know
how to steal i thought they was the
police bringing so much money home
i got to question them i thought you
didn't know how to steal but see
they think so much about their self they
want to impress their man so much they
don't want to give them the real
so they would learn how to steal from
other prostitutes
they don't think i know it but as long
as the money was coming it was good with
me
a lot of a lot of people outside
your this world uh think pimps are
always
intimidating and forcing girls to do
this it's by choice it's not about force
i don't know no players no pimps no mac
that forces a woman
to go get his money that's a black
eyebrow to come again you don't do that
all you do is talk because a woman gonna
be a prostitute anyway some of them
this don't have no man and no guidance
you have to have a man see a man thinks
from his mind a woman thinks from his
heart
all she knew was how to go get the money
the man got to know what to do next with
it
and that's what his woman gonna respect
if you jack off everything you get
pretty soon that woman gonna go to
somebody else and know what to do
i'm sure you've seen some crazy things
in all your years i've seen some awful
crazy things in my life you know
but one thing i can say i always stuck
by the rules of the game i always
played fair i played straight
never with no [ __ ] with me and i
still stick by that
so so the laws have changed since uh
back in the 80s 70s whenever
there's much much stricter penalties now
yeah laws have changed yeah they give
you
[ __ ] 60 to 80 years when they ever gave
it three years
so that's changed the way you guys do
business right
well me myself i changed all together i
elevated my whole life
uh
the average person couldn't even begin
to comprehend
the way my game go because they haven't
elevated to that point they haven't been
taught that
so i don't be upset because they don't
understand it's
it's a lot of haters now because they
don't understand how the next man is
doing
the next man is doing because he's doing
things above
average like i said big game is played
out of sight
yeah see i think what a lot of people
don't understand about pimping is
it it has such a wide range from the top
to the bottom
and no doubt you're the top of the food
chain that's right but down here on skid
row there's the bottom of the food chain
that's right and they look very
different they behave very different and
they
their girls look very different
everything i had guys that had
prostitutes for years
and they was never able to buy a car
him in the prostitute both would walk
they couldn't elevate
i've been driving brand new since 1963.
i even had 20 cars
and i'm still riding brand new
out all these years because
your dress code your your houses
your furniture you have to live in a
first-class way to be a first-class guy
you just can't talk it you got to walk
it and a lot of people just be blowing
wind
and uh they scream it but they don't
mean it
deep down inside they don't mean it i'm
serious about what i do
and i know what it takes to win
but what uh what kind of cars have you
driven over the years
well i started out driving brand new
cadillacs
i bro them every year
then after so many years went by like 20
30 years squares started driving
cadillac so you couldn't tell them from
the players so how to take it to the
next level i jumped two mercedes
car vets after that then i broke to the
golden spirit zimmer
i rode that uh until they took it from
that's one of the cars they took from
it they took all my cars and everything
so i
i had the the rolls royce the golden
speed examiner the corvette the bench
i had 20 other cars i mean 17 other cars
uh 16 or 17 other calls they've taken
so what i'm saying is i always
like to be on top you always want to
drive something nobody else can't reach
that show you uh where your game is at
you know and that's what players reach
for to congrat
come together and everybody floss
what they been doing it tells a lot
about your game you know
if you can't come in and stand up to the
plate then you just be weeded out
you want to be weeded in you don't want
to be weeded out so
right now i'm driving rolls royces i got
rolls royce's bentleys
i got mercedes got range rovers
i got got it all you know because that's
what the game is all about
that's what tells a lot about you
walking to the homes they're so flowers
and beautiful swimming pools
lakes and you know there's a big giant
players live for
it ain't about the famous about your
name the man
makes everything that's happened
man makes money money don't make man so
you got to stand up to what you
represent
and that's how i came up and that's how
i'm standing up to it today all these
years
all right virgil thank you much thank
you for sharing your story all right
thank you
you